YOU GO TO GET ON THE OTHER
SIDE WILL GET SOME COFFEE OR
SOMETHING RIGHT BACK TO YOU
LIKE FUN AND IF YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR ACTIVITIES TO ENJOY BEFORE
SCHOOL STARTS BACK UP WE HAVE
A WILD OPTION FOR YOU AND THE
FAMILY WORLD LION DAY IS
COMING UP AND THE LION HABITAT
RANCH IS CELEBRATING ALL
WEEKEND ROCKIES THERE LIVE TO
GET A PREVIEW OF WHAT TO
EXPECT.
ROCKY HOW'S IT GOING OUT
THERE.
HOW LOVE FROM BY LION
HABITAT RANCH THE NEEDS ARE AS
A KEEPER HERE IS HELPING US
FEED. RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE EVER
FAT ALLY AND YET NOT YOU CAN
DO IT HERE OKAY SO YOU'RE
READY READY. SO BELL AS I AM
NOT AFRAID BY THE WAY. I GOT
TO BE CALM AHEAD AND THAT THE
MUBARAK FOR USE AT THAT LOOK
AT THAT. SO 3 BALL. HOW MUCH
THEY EAT IT ON THE FEMALES AND
EAT ANYWHERE BETWEEN 5 POUNDS
A DAY AND THE MAIL SO EAT
ANYWHERE BETWEEN 7 AND A HALF
AND 12 POUNDS A DAY OF A LOT
OF ALL TELL YOU SHE'S NEVER
SEEN A DAY IN HER LIFE EXTRA
LAS VEGAS, NOT RIGHT I THINK
YOU GUYS.
OKAY, WOW WAS NOT ACTUALLY
INVIGORATING IT WAS VERY
EXCITING. OKAY, SO TELL US SO
BELLA IS 14 YEARS OLD USUALLY
MY AND TO LIVE ABOUT 7 TO 12
YEARS IN THE WILD ABOUT 15 TO
20 YEARS IN HUMAN CARE. ALL
RIGHT WE GOT ONE MORE I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU KNOW THIS ABOUT
THEY NATURALLY LIKE TO ON
OTHER ANIMALS COOP TO DISGUISE
OR SMELL LIKE A WOW THAT'S BIG
KNOW THAT'S WHAT SO THEY ROLL
AROUND WHO CAN WE SPARE FUN
WHICH IS NEXT TUESDAY, WE'RE
CELEBRATING HERE AT LION
HABITAT RANCH. THIS WEEKEND
SATURDAY AND SUNDAY. WHAT DO
YOU WHAT CAN THE COMMUNITY
EXPECT WHAT CAN FAMILIES DO
THIS WEEKEND. ACTUALLY BE ABLE
TO DO A SCAVENGER HUNT LEARN
ABOUT LIFE AND THEN ALSO IF
YOUR 14 OR UNDER YOU CAN DRESS
UP AS A LION AND ALLIANCE
WHAT YOU JUST SAID LOCAL AND
OF COURSE IT'S ALL ABOUT
ENRICHMENT AND TAKING CARE OF
THE LIONS HERE I JUST WANT TO
LET YOU GUYS KNOW.
THIS RIGHT HERE ARE GEARING
UP TO WATCH THE LIONS PREMIUM
THEIR LIONS HERE COME ON DOWN
THIS WEEK INSIDE A FUN DAY
FROM 10:00AM TO I'LL SEND IT